how do you go about proving this okay I
think I mentioned before essentially
what you want to use is the index laws
okay I will use some of the earlier you
know their laws as well so that's why
they're in that order I'm just gonna
jump straight into you because it's the
one that I used in my previous proof
previous question it's all I do I'm
gonna need to introduce some new
language here right so for instance
these two here I I want to translate
these from log equations into index
equations because then I can use the
index Lord Commander
right so for instance let's say let log
base a of X that's that that equal one
number and let's let log base a of y
equal another okay now I'm gonna rewrite
both of these in index form so then I
can use the index laws that I know can
you see by the way even though this has
nothing to do an induction the logic is
kind of similar
cuz I'm try to rewrite things in such a
way that I can use the walls I know in
cept in induction it was just using the
assumption that I know right so I can
but let's let's do this if I rewrite
this in index form it's that I start
with the mess okay so the base of the
law is the same as the base of the thing
that's being raised to power okay here's
where things websites
okay so M is the power and and of course
this is exactly the same but for the
other letters so if I call this one
this - how am I gonna stop moving
towards what I'm required to prove a few
different ways I'm gonna go from the
right hand side because what I've got
here breathing in x4 is very easy to
turn into the right hand side right so
if I say 1/2 okay I'm gonna get X on Y
right on the right hand side that is so
I've got x over Y over there and what do
I have over here I've got a to become on
a to the end now on the left hand side I
can do some stuff with my index Lord
right can you see this is why I bother
to rewrite it this way I already know
it's established that if I'm subtracting
sorry if I'm dividing indices right for
instance yeah to the power of 5/2
squared right
that would be so your kids because 32
divided by 4 is 8 so therefore I can
learn that as a and the right-hand side
hasn't changed now at this point I've
done my index little part that's a
little bit like using the assumption
because I'm assuming now I will need to
reintroduce the walks okay
so because I got rid of you here are
gonna bring them back right so I'm going
to take the left hand side and the right
hand side and I'm gonna take the log of
both sides okay and since I'm dealing in
base a I'll take log base a of the whole
thing right so I've got aide
and long face hey it's what so he ah
again it depends on what water you
choose to prove your things here right
I'm gonna take he up m- n that's the
power of the argument right likes it so
I'm gonna bring that it out and be the
coefficient sometime like em - him
yeah see I'm almost there if you
remember what M and actually are and
then what I'm left with is log base a of
a you see how the person will be on each
other right and of course the right hand
side is actually already in the state I
want it to be log base a of a is what
power do I have to raise a to to get egg
right which is just 1 and M minus M is
these original times here right so I'm
actually done at this point log base a
of X minus log base a of Y which is
equal to I already have the right hand
side as I wanted okay so that's what a
proof looks like I had to be honest I
think the hottest - Nadia because you
have to know what you're going to prove
in them and introduce some stuff that
would get me there I think the rest of
it actually